So, sometimes it feels like
users are from Earth and
monetization is from Mars.
What do we know about users?
>> We know that most of
them favor free apps.
In 2014, over 90% of the apps that
were downloaded were free apps.
Users wish to avoid paying upfront,
but they don't mind paying
in the right moment when they see
the value in front of their eyes.
This is the reason most apps
are using in app payments.
>> Okay.
So users prefer free apps, but
they don't mind paying once
the app proves its value.
So besides in app purchases,
what other models do we have?
>> We have many monetization options.
In-app billing,
you can sell digital goods and
real goods to your users
from the free app.
In app payments,
you let your user purchase item, level,
points, special tools from your app.
Ads, we got lots of options
with different types like
display advertising, in text links,
videos, and many more.
The important thing to note here
is that you wish to blend the ad
into your experience and
not to interrupt it.
Another opportunity is with affiliate.
You could make money by
referring to other services.
Ahh, and there's lots of other models
if you want to check if they
are appropriate to your case.
Email campaigns, selling data,
auction, flash sales,
merchandising, premium support and
many more.
>> That's a lot of models.
I mean, how do you know that
you're choosing the right one?
>> It's a real challenge.
We will provide more information
that will help you get
to those answers in the next lessons.
One thing to take from this lesson is
that your goal is to deliver direct
monetization to the right
user at the right time.